infinity get infinity is on the
offensive says car test a michelle
austyn maha the q30 was the infinities
first venture into the compact class and
now they're expanding the series with a
crossover QX 30 it to boasts a typical
infinity design the QX 30 completes
infinities compact series the crossovers
design is both elegant and powerful the
Japanese carmakers signature double arts
grill and I inspired LED headlights make
for a striking front end look
the three sweeping a symmetrical lines
are reminiscent of flowing water making
for an elegant and dynamic appearance
the QX 30 comes in only one engine
variant a 2.2 litre turbocharged diesel
a further demonstration that this
crossover was conceived as an add-on to
the q30 series the q30 and QX 30 are
assembled at the Sunderland plant in
England making them the first infinities
built both in and for Europe the QX
thirties trunk holds an ample 430 litres
the QX 30 is both sporty and stylish the
suspension keeps the car comfortably
quiet with no loss and responsiveness
the powertrain is borrowed from
mercedes-benz and delivers the expected
state-of-the-art performance all-wheel
drive and the 7-speed dual-clutch
transmission are standard
delanco em quick she'll says the
steering and the QX 30 is responsive and
gives a good feel for the road Infiniti
engineers wanted to make sure the
steering would be neither too sensitive
or too sluggish and they succeeded Olga
notice on the upper shaft the
collaboration between daimler and
renault-nissan is especially apparent in
the interior only the logo on the
steering wheel was changed the buttons
switches and levers will be familiar to
Mercedes drivers and the layout is
exactly the same as in the Mercedes GLA
as the in almost michelle says the
interior is both elegant and luxuriously
equipped but it does feel slightly
cramped inside all the controls are
within reach but they seem a bit crammed
together nice what a bouncy it's a
strong country over a look is appealing
but on this high gloss bar you'll see
every little smudge right off the bat
that's a minus point in Michelle's book
mindful of it the 2.2 litre turbocharged
diesel engine generates 125 kilowatts
and accelerates from zero to one hundred
and eight point five seconds top speed
is 215 kilometers an hour Infiniti says
the QX 30 consumes 4.9 litres per 100
kilometers infiniti QX 30 has just two
centimeters more ground clearance than
the q30 and visually the only difference
are the touches of plastic on the lower
end of the bumpers overall michelle is
happy with the QX 30s handling it has a
nice grip on the road and the seats are
comfortable the only drawback is the
slightly cramped feel in the driver's
seat here in the fire cabina and father
mother finding fela the QX 30 retails in
Germany starting at close to thirty nine
thousand euros that's about a thousand
less than the Mercedes GLA which sports
an identical engine so there's a price
advantage and the infiniti model has
more features
let's keep your auto fees there are
places you don't normally have access to
like this one it may be hard to believe
sis card test amatis kirat but this
place is top secret it's the track where
mercedes-benz test prototypes on
different kinds of pavement everything
is set up for Mercedes to demonstrate an
entirely new type of vehicle when I talk
about 3d presentation de gly start
finding a crowd of journalists are here
for the world premiere and here it comes
a truck and not just any truck mercedes
says this truck will revolutionize the
distribution of goods and cities 120
years after got leaked dimer built the
first motorized truck mercedes has
finally produced the first big
electrically powered truck
so my den Stefan Buckner the head of
Mercedes truck division says diesel
technology has served us well for many
decades electro technology has been
making great progress and passenger cars
mercedes is now building on that
technology with its new truck Buckner
expects electric motors to continue to
develop rapidly in the next few years
but what's really fueled development is
customer demand for emission-free
vehicles that make little or no noise
when they're on the road in cities
during all hours of day and night Louis
gavage arm and you start Alfonso Conan
this suite of times an update the Urban
II truck weighs about 1.7 tons more than
a conventional diesel powered truck the
batteries in the frame give it a range
of up to 200 kilometers between charges
of course Martha says there's more to an
electric truck than batteries and an
electric motor there are a lot of
peripheral technology to integrate
starting with this direct current socket
that can take on 150 kilowatts you won't
find such heavy duty sockets on the wall
right now they're limited to 50
kilowatts but higher capacity is surely
the wave of the future this holds the
charging electronics and this is where
the current is distributed during
charging and use and down here is a
transformer which is included because a
truck has a lot of equipment that takes
only 24 volts like the radio and all the
modern onboard electronics for Nicki
Minaj autauga shonsu hottia he doesn't
these are the radiator hoses and the
distributor I'm there's also a
high-voltage air compressor and a
combustion engine the auxiliary units
provide compressed air here it's
produced separately so that the driver
can operate the brakes adjust levers and
so forth sukadeva lengua Lyon on Savita
traditional truck technology also plays
an important role both Mumbai tamantha
says that in an ordinary internal
combustion truck a retarder builds up
enough resistance so that the driver
doesn't have to pump the brakes the
whole time when going downhill the
school year that saw with two braking
resistors if the truck has to break when
the battery is full electric energy is
diverted to the resistors it doesn't
vanish of course it's converted to heat
which can be used to heat the vehicle in
winter suba hi-yah fight i get the
electronically powered rear axle is
pretty much the same as in daimler's
evil hybrid bus with minor modifications
bleed posts fond I'm la now on decent
mood if it's your vote is he on to him
and the rear axle can also be steered
electrically so you need all sorts of
additional electronics to turn a regular
truck can do any traffic I didn't eat
trucks among the fuso canter e-cell is
much smaller but it's already on the
road in the 7.5 tonne class after
successful pilot testing and Portugal a
handful are now undergoing Road testing
in Germany the hair muss logistics
company is testing one of them and they
give it a thumbs up while the initial
costs are higher than for a diesel truck
its upkeep is much lower and that's
crucial in the logistics industry
as a reconnaissance a good for sure come
on CMO of thomas germany says he could
envision using more electric trucks as
long as they meet three criteria first
enough cargo space to carry the packages
second adequate range and last but not
least they have to make economic sense
mostly helps to handle such a few son
Mercedes goal is to eventually reach the
point where all truck traffic in the
city is emission-free it's like the
urban ii truck is still a prototype says
montes but shows what the future might
bring it will appear without camouflage
coloration at the iaa utility vehicle
show in September but it won't be on the
streets until at least 20 20 so until
then we'll have to put up with diesel
trucks in our cities MIT's deal Erica vs
Indian instead in a long GN
the British brand McLaren long famous in
Formula One racing is releasing its
sports series which will feature three
models designed for everyday driving all
three the 540 SI coupe a the 570 s coupe
a and the 570 GT used the same carbon
fiber mono cell chassis the 3.8 litre
biturbo engine is mid-mounted for
balanced output in the five 70s and the
GT is 419 kilowatts the gt's adaptive
suspension is a bit gentler than the
suspension in the s another highlight on
the GT is the side hinge trunk designed
to hold two pieces of bespoke luggage
that makes the 570 GT the first McLaren
ever two-sport a trunk
by the north of Jerusalem had old cooter
shows in Paris as cards as to eNOS paid
thing everyone wants to sit in the front
row today she's testing the Citroen ds3
convertible a car with french chick to
spare and even better we have front row
seats to enjoy the show the smallest of
the DS models is the Citroen ds3 since
the 1950s TS has stood for stylish and
elegant design in 2009 cinta when
revived the tradition with a whole
family of vehicles now the ds3 has
received its first facelift well test it
as a convertible with a 1.2 liter
three-cylinder gasoline engine which
generates 81 kilowatts of power eNOS
likes that at 1500rpm the engine is
already at its maximum torque of 205
Newton meters so the car has snappy
acceleration well even in the low rev
range new is the combination with a
6-speed automatic transmission which
shifts smooth as silk the ds3 Sprint's
from zero to one hundred and ten point
seven seconds that doesn't sound like
much but an everyday operation it's
frisky enough on the highway the little
French car has a top speed of 188
kilometers an hour
the front end of the ds3 is where the
design overhaul is most evident sit 2
n's trademark double angle logo on the
radiator grille has made way for a logo
unique to the DS family it looks like
the letters D and s headlights are also
nicely stylish the high-gloss anthracite
grey light alloy wheel rims are modern
and sporty the roof seems to float above
the body and just like oco-2 fashion
even the folding of the fabric on the
convertible roof is styled down to the
last detail
gunawan on the ds3 convertibles trunk is
only 30 liters smaller than in its
hardtop brother but the way that it
works is quite different eNOS likes that
the roof automatically moves upward when
she wants to open the trunk allowing the
trunk lid to open comfortably but the
trunk opening is rather small which
makes loading the trunk somewhat
difficult I landings most Afghans with a
pectus isn't flying home on tough candid
interaction Sheila's line it's summer so
we'll test the trunk with barbecue
equipment the charcoal is loaded with no
difficulty but the two halves of the
grill have to be taken apart to fit
through the opening
in the interior the driver is greeted
with the finest materials
the new 7-inch color touchscreen in the
middle console provides access to all
the vehicles functions it's eliminated
20 buttons including the radios volume
knob but finding the function you're
looking for will take a bit of practice
in another attractive touch the climate
control system has its own small
indicator it's easy to find the button
for the roof which can be opened or
closed at driving speeds up to 120
kilometers an hour depending on the
driving situation it can be rolled down
the entire length of the car or even
folded up on top of the trunk Tina says
that running the roof bag gives you a
true convertible feeling with the wind
in your hair it's like the essence of
summer but the drawback is that the
folded roof blocks much of the view from
the rearview mirror back then we can and
watch videos nexium for stats when the
roof is put into the middle position the
rear windshield is visible again and the
driver has a much better view options
for the ds3 include a front and rear
parking assist plus a rear view camera
that's a big help in parallel parking
the active city brake assist make city
driving safer by helping to prevent
low-speed collisions
and that's a penis as a ds3 convertible
costs two thousand eight hundred euros
more than a ds3 hardtop in Germany but
for that you get the fun of summer
open-air driving but eNOS does note a
few drawbacks first the trunk small
volume and especially its narrow opening
and second that the ds3 comes only with
two doors which also could be
inconvenient for everyday driving bus
even fight zymotic lana and slang wrong
with siblings
but if you're a fan of Oh keturah you're
happy to splash out for high style
comfort takes a backseat and just like
in couture fashion owners of a ds3 are
given plenty of choices to express their
own individual style the ds3 comes an 80
different roof and body color
combinations
cycling is one of the healthiest and
most environmentally friendly ways of
getting from A to B we believed followed
our car testify no dicen / says the
numbers bear this out with about seventy
two million bikes in Germany many people
who want to ride their own bike on
holiday bring it with them either on top
on the back or inside the car but safety
experts aren't too fond of roof bike
racks Klingons index patent beenish me
guys that herbert cutler owns a bike
shop and he's familiar with all the
different bike transportation systems
mother says roof racks are suited only
to lightweight racing bikes they're
easier to lift and the mounting
equipment doesn't have to be quite so
sturdy bikes on the roof may vibrate or
sway and that can be dangerous fairly
say so that leaves inside the car or on
the back hitch mounted bike racks are
especially useful on longer trips the
bike rack is attached to the trailer
hitch on the car a turn of the key and
the rack is secured then hook up the
electrical connection for the trailers
rear lights mount the bikes on the rack
and secure them
damn it i know'd has a few tips to make
mounting faster and easier it's best to
remove everything that's detachable and
heavy from your bike first that includes
the water bottle and the bike basket
then there's ebikes an e-bike can weigh
30 kilos and the battery is heavy and
expensive so it's best to remove the
battery and the speedometer which could
fall off and put those in your car
Vatutin spot Ian Dan the Tuskens elkwood
the number of bikes you can transport
depends on your car's permitted load
weight so be sure to check that first I
know it says it even if you're not
slowed down by Sun rain or other
glitches remember thieves are everywhere
so be sure to lock up your bikes too and
put a license plate on the rack since
your car's plate is hidden Sonia comea
your car will be longer with the rack on
it so parking aids won't work properly
and the extra weight also affects
handling
inside the car your bikes will travel in
comfort but you'll have less space for
passengers and cargo of course clamping
the bikes to an inside bike rack is a
simple process
that's what me bisazza seamless I note
says a universal system makes adjusting
the rack to the width of your car a snap
remove the bikes front wheel put the
bike in the trunk secure the bike fork
and you're done
whatever cooler says that if you have
expensive bikes inside racks are nice
because you're not risking scratches
damage or dirt and their theft proof so
inside your car your bikes will usually
be safe with the bike safely stowed
inside the car you can set off with an
inside rack driving speed isn't an issue
but rear mounted racks can come with
speed restrictions so be sure to check
your user's manual mounting instructions
and any rating plates on the rack and
whatever the speed limit for your rack
it's best to stay under 130 kilometers
an hour on the highway
flowing contours bereft of unsightly
corners and edges a streamlined design
that looks futuristic today but this car
is a cousin of the original Volkswagen
bug the man who created it was Ferdinand
Porsche and the car was a design
precursor to the production model that
would make his name world-famous the
Porsche 64 was a very limited edition
with just three built the aerodynamic
form helped boost its top speed to 160
km/h is that normally the Congress of
huge value to Porsche explains Thomas
gurnick co-founder of a classic cars
Museum in Hamburg it was one of
Ferdinand Porsches dreams he wanted to
build racing cars and products for the
people that folks now full of the bone
the Porsche 64 was created in 1939 in
parallel with the original volkswagen
the beetle Ferdinand Porsche was head of
VW at the time
the 64 was supposed to compete in a
high-profile Berlin to Rome race the
race was canceled due to the outbreak of
World War two a Porsche 64 would have
been among the favourites the
aerodynamics and lightweight
construction were ahead of their time I
like kavish 21 sign outside teases pots
like the 64 is housed in a museum
located in hamburg's redeveloped hafan
city docks area the unique collection on
display focuses on post-war German
racing car heritage and therefore
Porsche it was a personal mission for
Thomas Carnac and Oliver Schmidt damas
lying the two friends had always been
fascinated by Porsche models that
interest evolved over the years and
eventually they said there's more to
German post-war Motorsports than just
Porsche it was the post-war
reconstruction era that really
interested them a time when car makers
at very modest means of their disposal
in fosston metal hot altos and stun
isn't one of those pioneers was ultimate
a a racing driver from Austria he built
and drove this curious looking
contraption after his death in 1995 the
museum bought that Porsche Volkswagen
mongrel as well as much a spare parts
collection Thomas Kearney had no idea of
the treasure trove he'd accidentally
acquired
it was while rummaging around in old
boxes belonging to Matty the tomah
skirting discovered parts from the
second 64 model and now takes pride of
place in the museum
I thought the biggest problem was the
missing body he recalls they took the
model they already had as a template but
each model was experimental so there
were a lot of differences cities and
thoughts I keep this fellow interceded
ie designs and and thoughts like a
vacation scientist Raghava restoring
that second 64 to its former glory took
the best part of a decade but you won't
find this beauty gracing the streets in
terms of automotive historical value its
inestimable the four-cylinder boxer
engine with a displacement just short of
one leader was a product of Volkswagen
the air-cooled engine with two
carburetors generated about 35
horsepower design mother this unique
aerodynamic body was designed by Aaron
chaminda the man behind the design of
the Volkswagen as well as the
record-breaking Mercedes t-80 later on
all these projects were overseen by
Ferdinand Porsche the specifications
book from back then must have included
elements of the Volkswagen in lamented
as folk songs we don't surf in monsey TR
you can recognize the form of the beetle
in their ribbing here in the hood at the
front and then at the rear we find these
air inlets that weren't featured in the
beetle to those in the know will
recognize what you could call a squash
beetle than I'm home box while conducted
hook from kaifa and the basis for later
rear-engine Porsche models the 356 and
the 911 the interior is pure portion
sober or even Spartan
the awesome 64 the first racing car ever
to bear the famous Porsche name
you